[Music]
take me somewhere hey what's up you guys
yeah happy
monday
uh how many people are in here i can't
see
six and rising oh okay there we go there
we go yeah so yeah uh a couple of y'all
recommended this movie which i had been
wanting to watch actually because yeah
they had just added it on shutter
and this is
mad god
now this was made by phil tippett now if
you don't know who phil tippett is
he's kind of like one of the
animation particularly stop-motion
animation but he does computer stuff too
like going way back to the 80s i mean he
worked on the original star wars trilogy
he worked on robocop uh jurassic park
starship troopers willow dragon heart
dragon slayer honey i shrunk the kids
the twilight movies um just [ __ ] tons of
stuff and actually more recently he
opened his own uh animation studio in 84
i think
and they've been working on recently
they're working on the new um dc movie
black adam
uh they did uh you know the mandalorian
they worked on that they worked on book
of boba fett like all kind of stuff like
some of the marvel movies so
the dude is like a legend
um he does like i said other kinds of
animation too but stop motion is kind of
his thing
now mad god i think this kind of became
sort of like a long awaited kind of
thing that people wanted to see because
he actually started working on this
back in the 80s
um
i think right around the time that
robocop 2 was coming out because you
know how he started doing like
stop-motion on jurassic park and then
they decided that they were going to go
with the computer generated graphics and
he basically said to himself well i
guess now computer graphics are coming
in so stop motion isn't a thing anymore
so he took mad god and just kind of like
shelved it
so it basically like sat on a shelf
unfinished for like 20 something years
is that old parts of it until yeah some
of it are i mean obviously it's all been
you wouldn't know you wouldn't know
because it all looks very consistent but
when he kind of like pulled it back out
like i guess when stop motion started
getting like people started appreciating
it as an art form and some of the other
people at uh his studio like saw it and
they were like dude we should finish
this
so he got um he got on kickstarter he
raised some money on there and he got
like a whole bunch of volunteers like a
bunch of people that would come in and
work on it for free just because they
were students and they wanted to learn
from him or something like that so this
is kind of like a labor of love for him
he'd been working on it like i said he
had the idea back in the 80s and he only
just recently finished it so everybody
was like really looking forward to it
coming out and then it finally came out
on shutter i think that it's also doing
um it's also doing a limited theatrical
release like a kind of art house
theaters and things like that
and i mean i have to say this is
incredible to look at i mean it's
amazing looking yeah visually and the
music and everything it's like a big
long
kind of like a
audio visual
thing almost kind of like watching a
long music video in a way of
hellish imagery
looks like something i don't know it's
got its own look kind of like something
i don't know nine inch nails or
something it's it's it it's cool
it's not real coherent it doesn't have
any
spoken
dialogue in it
it's just this army of
weird-looking world war one guys and gas
masks and it's all stop motion
they're lowered down
into the underground on a damn wire
it gets miles and miles down there into
like this hellish
landscape it's kind of like hellish with
[ __ ]
industry and
medical procedures and dead bodies and
tanks and fighting and
weird [ __ ] he's just going down there
with a briefcase with a bomb in it
to complete some mission
but he gets captured and
they drill through his head and they
take a damn weird looking baby out of
him it doesn't make any sense it's just
like something happening in hell
but it is weird it's real weird to watch
it's about yeah there's like a really
lot of grotesque imagery in it yeah um
it doesn't the thing about it and like
he's been interviewed about this and he
basically said a quote from him that i
found uh he calls this a reflection of
the absurdity of the world i live in
okay where he kind of sees the world as
just uh being overrun with like cruelty
and greed and things like that but the
thing about this it also has i don't
know there's a lot of interpretations to
it like i said there's no dialogue
um
i mean things happen in it but it
doesn't really have a plot per se it's
more like
it's more like a series of images that
could like mean a lot of things like
depending it's kind of i kind of got
like a just like a creation destruction
narrative like a cyclical
kind of thing and like i said there's
kind of like a bashian
you know like kind of thing to it too
it's almost like
i don't know it's
i didn't get the sense that it was
hopeful
but
i kind of more got the sense that it was
like really cynical in the sense that
you're sending this person like down
into hell and it's almost kind of like
the same thing as like repeating over
and over and then like the whole thing
blows up and then like at the end you
kind of think oh it's like it created
this whole new world but then that one
kind of starts to decay too
so it's open to a lot of interpretations
and i mean i kind of feel like he even
said the older i get the less i worry
about what the [ __ ] it means or anything
like that he's basically just going with
his gut instincts what he wants it to
look like and then which in a way is
kind of good because you can kind of
like
put your own meaning onto it yeah to me
it was just like [ __ ] happens
[Laughter]
it's just one kind of weird scene after
another after another after another and
there is a little bit of continuity
but you don't really have to follow it
you can just chill it chill out just
kind of observe it and enjoy enjoy it
for how it looks
and just weird disturbing things happen
in it one right after another
i mean it does kind of feel like he
pulled it out of his ass but it's it's
visually pleasing it's just art
yeah it's just art you know and like i
said it's i saw it as a good um
demonstration of what could be and what
should be done with stop-motion
stop-motions come a long way if you do
it right i mean this looks amazing yeah
these are little miniatures
but you can't really tell they're
miniatures
the thing has a [ __ ] huge scope it
seems like really big places you know
this is taking
place in and you can do a lot of really
cool effects with stop motion now [ __ ]
that's
it looks really good you know it kind of
reminded me of a little bit of that
blood machines
yeah the look of it is kind of yeah the
tone was kind of like blood machines but
it's stop motion
and
i wish they would have just continued
with blood machines i you know i know i
think that i think blood machines just
said all it had to say
it was you know dudes turning women into
machines and i guess they didn't want to
go anywhere else with it
but
that that should have been a whole
series i would like to see a lot more
stories in that universe
and um this one
was kind of like that
but without without without a cohesive
narrative over it it's just kind of like
a demonstration of what can be done with
stop motion that's the way i looked at
it i mean they had good music you know
yeah i really liked the sound design
actually the guy that did the sound
design uh i can't remember his name but
he would had actually won an oscar for
that and he actually volunteered to work
on this for free because like i said
phil tippett is like a legend in you
know animation and stop-motion and stuff
like that so
a lot of people worked like volunteered
to work on it just because they wanted
to work on it and it was kind of like i
said a labor of love for him what you
could do is you could take a movie like
this
and redo it
and put a story in it and you'd and like
a cohesive narrative maybe make a series
taking place in that universe and it'd
be like really it would have been really
cool like say pardon the heavy metal
universe like the mac you know yeah
because it kind of gave me that kind of
vibe i like some out of heavy metal i
mean this reminded me
in a way you can kind of tell and when
we said like compared to like sort of
like blood machines blood machines is
recent but it's it's retro in the sense
that they're trying to make it look like
the 80s kind of it has like an 80s
kind of new retro wave vibe to it kind
of kind of like a high-tech but dark and
kind of sinister flash gordon with
really
high technology to produce it but real
retro kind of
the characters had real weird retro
technology but it was it was a lot
but it's shot in a lot better you know a
[ __ ] cg and it's just good you know
just goes to show you what could have
what you could do with a flash gordon
type
story nowadays if it looked right
i mean [ __ ] blood machines looked
wild i liked it i liked it that i i
could have had a whole series of movies
in that style in that universe
this it's just not long enough it was
you know like four or five small little
episodes and they were kind of more like
music videos in a way
just real visual oriented
it wasn't
the story to me wasn't that satisfying
but i liked it i really liked blood
machines i wish there was more of it
i mean what i was to say though was that
you know that was modern but had an 80s
take to it this one
seems like you can kind of i don't want
to say you can kind of tell that it was
conceived in the 80s because it's not
exactly like that it's kind of hard to
explain
but it reminded me of
a lot of these really weird like arty
kind of [ __ ] that came back do you
remember like do you guys remember i
think it was maybe like the early 90s
when mtv had liquid television like that
had all this like weird like animation
clips on it yes it reminded me of
something you'd see on there but like a
million times better produced
now like i said [ __ ] does happen in it
it's not like
just random it's not a random series of
images it is like you know one thing
happening after another it's just that
it's open to interpretation so don't go
into it thinking that it has like a
traditional narrative because it does
just kind of enjoy it it's
a lot of the look is kind of like it's
it's full color it's kind it's
futuristic looking but it's hellish
with kind of a 1920s art deco type of
motif a lot of machines that showed look
like something out of the damn 1920s and
uniforms and stuff and then it has like
some medical stuff that happens and
weird it's just weird [ __ ] you know the
man flick and
and then just also kind of reminded me
if it had kind of like a medical horror
themes
looked like something out of some weird
yeah there's i mean it's there's a lot
of grotesque this is definitely a horror
movie that's for sure it's it has like a
lot of really grotesque imagery there's
gore there's poop
you know there's like you know there's
[ __ ] like that so i mean that one scene
where
he goes down because i looked up on
wikipedia
and the little characters and stuff like
that do have nate they don't have names
but they have like
you know they have things that they're
called so the little guy that goes down
in the diving bell first with the little
gas mask and everything he's called the
assassin okay
now so they give him a map
and he has a suitcase with do you find
out later has a bomb in it
and he goes down and so he's just going
through this like like i said like
hellish court sort of uh you know series
of
places
and looking for something in particular
because he keeps looking and like
tapping on his map like saying and the
map like keeps falling apart too like
well he's like every time he takes out
his pocket like little pieces fall off
and he goes through this one place where
there's these big giant people i mean
he's like this big and they're like
[ __ ] enormous yeah the big soldiers
and they're all in
they're all sitting in electric chairs
and they're all sitting there being
electrocuted and there's like holes in
the bottoms of the chairs and it looks
like essentially like diarrhea like
coming out
and then like it goes down into all
these tubes and pipes and all the pipes
go down and like go into this other
thing and like things are like made out
of that
so there's very much like there's a
whole thing where like a baby is like
squooshed and like an alchemist like
makes it into
like dust dust and then it and then
turns it into like a like a um what do
you call it like from 2001 a space
odyssey
a monolith and then like it goes and
like makes another universe or something
like that so it's very much like that
kind of trippy
imagery but like i said it's real
disgusting like there's one point where
the first assassin because there's
actually two but um the first assassin
gets
taken by
like this surgeon and the nurse and they
cut open
his chest cavity and like they're
digging around and they're like throwing
there's gore and they're pulling all
this stuff out of his chest like jewelry
and
like books and stuff like that but like
a bunch of like goop and stuff too and
then they pull a baby out and it's like
but i mean
honestly one of my favorite images in
this is the plague doctor
the character you know what i mean it's
this really really big
like it looks like a plague doctor but
it's got like this big hat and it's like
all these kind of like bones and stuff
like hanging from it kind of floats and
it has like all these little pieces of
like wispy like black material like kind
of floating behind it and it's like it's
really really cool looking that's the
thing that comes and gets the baby and
then they squirt like i said it's not
like you can spoil anything because
it's just a mystifying and then there is
some live action in it too because
there's a human character and the whole
time i'm watching it i'm like that dude
looks so [ __ ] familiar he's called
the last man by the way and i looked it
up it's alex cox that's the guy that
directed uh sid and nancy and repo man
he's like a punk rock filmmaker he's
made like a [ __ ] ton of movies and
documentaries and stuff and i was like i
do that [ __ ] look familiar i
just hadn't seen him in a long time but
yeah so alex cox is in this uh and he
sends down another little assassin
and
then like different [ __ ] happens to that
guy but it's just kind of like yeah this
is like it's it's super bizarro it's
really bizarre it's just a trippy
experience yeah like something you'd see
when you were a kid back in the 70s
you're going to watch the [ __ ] movie
heavy metal or something but
or you just
it's definitely the cult film you know
yeah it's good yeah i i really
appreciated it more as like a demo
of what you actually could do with stop
motion i mean the sets in this were
incredible i would really actually i
think there's a documentary out there
somewhere like um that's behind the
scenes and i'd like to see how big
these environments are yeah i was
thinking that while i was watching it it
looked like yeah because i would make
all these models and film them and stop
motion but yeah because this is
old-school stop-motion this isn't
because nowadays you can do it like a
little bit there's things to help you
out yeah but no he did this absolutely
move a little bit take a picture move a
little bit take a picture and it's so
fluid it's real smooth
you don't uh it's jerky yeah
it looks it looks really good and then
there's things like flames in it and it
looks like real fire which i imagine
it's superimposed in there there's a lot
of photography in it
but uh yeah you can you can and the the
lighting's really good and
just you know making environments out of
damn junk basically but it looks really
good you know i mean they're so
they must have like spent ages i mean
the the environments are just like so
meticulous because they're walking
through like i said these hellish
environments like there's like they
almost kind of look like big junkyards
or things like that and like when he
goes down with his little bomb suitcase
and then he goes down to the place where
he's supposed to leave it and there's a
big pile of other suitcases
there which kind of like on the
wikipedia page it says that he's
supposed to leave the suitcase there
because it'll blow up all the other ones
but i interpreted it as he's not the
first one to do this and the whole and
the whole enterprise was futile yeah it
never does blow up because it never does
blow up yeah so i'm kind of like well
he's just the latest in a line of like
that and everybody's doing it's almost
kind of like i i saw it as kind of like
a like a sisyphean kind of task where
it's just kind of like he just keeps
sending down these little assassins
knowing that nothing's going to come of
it and that's what all of those like
piles of but i guess it could mean
either thing i don't know but there is
like explosions and stuff that happened
later because there's like mushroom
clouds and [ __ ] like that and it's not
the thing about it the imagery is all
really hellish and like really grotesque
and everything but then there's that one
scene in there that's like really
beautiful you know that roll like that
neon place it looks like all happy and
trippy and like there's all these
mushrooms with like all the bright
colors and everything and it's like that
so
i mean yeah this is just like amazing to
look at like i said don't don't go into
it expecting it to be like a movie in
the sense of it having like a narrative
thrust or anything like that but
it's just i mean as a piece of art it's
just incredible it looks incredible it
sounds incredible uh there's a lot of
babies crying in there so you know you
might wanna but it's just if you're into
like grotesque visuals at all like you
definitely should watch it because it's
just just kind of like relax and let it
sort of like wash over you don't try to
like figure it out or anything like that
because like i said i don't even think
phil tippett you know he i don't think
he ever came out and said oh it means
this that and the other thing no they
just added to it these kids i mean you
can tell that he is like you know there
is symbolism in there and you can but
like i said it's open to interpretation
so it's kind of like in segments though
things meant something in inside a
certain scene and then i think it ended
and then it goes into a next one and
then the next one the next like episodes
almost they're not they're not totally
related but
i also like that that the last man
played by alex cox like i said that he
was the guy making the maps well he
wasn't making the maps he had like a
bunch of witches
like underneath the table like in his
laboratory they were making the maps
like sewing it together i'm like okay
have a bunch of witches under the table
as one does um
yeah slasher fred points out liquid
television is the show that beavis and
butthead uh and eon flux got their start
on yes that's true um
eon flux i always kind of liked that
animation but i but i'd be lying if i
said i knew what the [ __ ] was going on
in that cartoon you can get them all
together she's just a secret agent yeah
i figured that out but it's just kind of
like a lot of it i was just kind of like
okay whatever there was a lot of really
good uh [ __ ] on there i used to like um
winter steel which was actually more
puppets than animation and uh art school
girls of doom that one was good too but
yeah there was a lot of really good uh
animation clips on there the eon flux
movie sucked that's what yeah i was just
gonna say pat asked what do we think
about it i didn't think it sucked i just
thought it was like really mediocre
yeah well that's the same thing yeah it
was just kind of mad yeah
and it wasn't as it wasn't nearly as
weird as the cartoon was i mean they
were trying to make it like normal yeah
it wasn't as weird as the cartoon it
wasn't as [ __ ] just psycho you know
the cartoon was just [ __ ] psycho
yeah it was it was totally bizarre like
i said i really liked it but most of the
time i just got like what the actual
[ __ ] is going on right now but but
that's kind of what was intriguing about
it is you didn't really know what was
going on
they're talking about other stop-motion
uh animation somebody mentioned clash of
the titans which is actually one of my
favorite yeah that was uh one of ray
harryhausen's last ones danny rowling
says coraline was a real good
stop-motion flick it was yeah and that
was uh that's based on the neil gaiman
book right yeah and i really really
liked um yeah i really liked the look of
that actually i would like i wouldn't
mind seeing that one again i think i saw
that in the theater when it came out and
it's
ostensibly it's a kids movie but
that's it's pretty [ __ ] scary i mean
for kids like especially like the other
mother with the butt knives and all that
kind of [ __ ] that's it's [ __ ] weird i
mean it's neil gaiman so you know what i
mean the book was actually a little bit
scarier because i read the book too um
so they toned it down slightly for the
movie but not much uh not much i would
like to see the like a more scary
version but coraline was at was actually
like really really good
um a stop-motion shining would be cool
to see
oh no that's an intriguing proposition
isn't it it would have to be like the
kubricki and shining
like a stop-motion one i think that'd be
kind of awesome
dj maniac said i was gonna try and watch
this today before work but it seems way
too heady
yeah i mean
yeah this is definitely one it's it's
visual you can't just like put it on and
like go fart around and do something
else you have to like sit there and
watch it it's not super long i think
it's only 82 minutes or something like
that but
yeah you definitely have to like watch
the whole thing like closely because
you'll miss [ __ ] especially if you just
want to see
all the detail that was put into this
because i was just my mind was blown the
whole time looking around at all the
environments and how much time it must
have taken to build
all of that stuff because it's just
there's so many there's so many
environments that the little characters
are moving through
that
jesus i was like that must have taken
[ __ ] forever
and i was like
i was uh i was reading an article about
this and somebody commented
something and i was like yeah i relate
to that they said they're like wow i
wish i had this much commitment to
anything ever yeah i mean that this guy
like started this back in the 80s and
then kind of like put it away for a
while and then took it back out and then
like the fact that he had and he had all
these volunteers like i said students
and stuff that would come and work on it
with them like every weekend and
just
the patience that you would have see i
see stop motion animation i love it like
as an art form i love to watch it but i
could never do it i'm just like way too
impatient like for that kind of you have
to just
be so i'm sure it's very zen you know
and it's like really relaxing but i
could i couldn't do that so like mad
respectful people that like got a bunch
of bizarre stuff and it's kind of like
if you like silent hill you'd probably
like it it's kind of some of that stuff
is like something out of silent hill
everything is everything in this movie
is like so tactile like it's like
everything looks slimy and bloody and
poopy and like this and there's like
there's like creatures with like their
with fur and they're like actual real
human teeth and [ __ ] like that it's like
it's [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] up and now that i'm talking
about it i actually wouldn't mind
watching it again
just to like look at all the creatures
because i was like so overwhelmed that i
feel like i missed a lot of stuff
so i don't know so i'm gonna have to
like watch it again at some point but
yeah i mean if you're into this stop
motion at all and especially if you're
into like real grotesque kind of [ __ ]
then yeah you should probably watch it
just don't expect there to be a story
because there's not really not really
but um i thought it was just a good demo
yeah i mean it's it's a visual trip out
wow
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you can just
like sit there and watch it and listen
to it like all the weird [ __ ] sounds
and the weird score and everything like
that and the little things that happen
on the scene and then it goes into the
next scene yeah it's super weird it's
super weird
uh hugo said i worked on a stop-motion
series with seth rogen beautiful puppets
and sets but it tanked okay
it was too woke
okay
uh stop motion series what would that be
i didn't know they you guys should
review the silent hill movies they're
awesome i've seen how many of them are
there now because i've only seen the
first one and i remember liking that one
although i never played the video games
um
but i remember the first movie being
like pretty good the first one is anyway
okay so the other ones aren't really all
that good
i yeah maybe we should do that one we
should probably do silent hill at some
point maybe we should watch it tonight
if i can find it i don't know i haven't
seen it a long time i think
i think i remember watching that like
back when i was at that my apartment so
that was what back in 2010 or 2011 or
something like that when the [ __ ] did
that movie came out is it really that
old
holy [ __ ] i guess it must be i never
seen the movies
yeah i mean like i said i remember the
first one being good i didn't bother
seeing the other ones though i'm sure
like people that are more into the video
game like got more out of it but i
thought it was like pretty creepy and
enjoyable all right so uh you seem to be
not talking anymore
i can't invent more to say about it all
right so i guess well we went off for
half an hour so that's okay all right so
uh we'll be back tomorrow i'm not sure
what movie we'll be talking about
because we'll have to find something to
watch uh later tonight so we can talk
about it tomorrow uh so thanks everybody
for dropping by and we will see you guys
again tomorrow evening
bye